[موسيقى]
وحتى بتشوف الناس بتكون مبسوطه وانت لما
تقدمي لهم اشي بتكون يعني في
ايجابي منك ومنهم اكيد شعور بالفرح
اني الاقل حضان والناس المحتاجين اكيد
شعور بالعطاء والعطاء ما له حدود اغتنام
وشهري رمضان في عمل الخير له وجه اخر هنا
فتحت عنوان سبيل صويلح يحضر مجموعه من
الشباب وجبات الافطار للعوائل العفيفه كما
يقومون بالبحث عن اي محتاج تعفف عن السؤال
نقوم بتوزيع ما لا يقل عن 100 صدر يوميا
ويصل العدد في بعض الايام الى 130 140 صدر
يوميا بفضل الله تعالى
نستهدف من يعني عملنا بفضل الله تعالى
الاخوه الذين يستحقون عملنا في هذا الشهر
المبارك وما وضع اقتصادي صعب وسوء احوال
الكثير من المواطنين تقدم هذه المبادرات
الرمضانيه جل ما يحتاجه كثيرون في شهر شرع
ابوابه لاعمال الخير سها جميل العربيه
عمان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات